the girl on my cell the one who I was
like okay this is I'm gonna tell you
this story okay I'm sorry I'm all over
the place she may give the names away
look at look at Amy she comes on my show
and she's she okay I did we're talking a
show about body count right how many
bodies Too Many Bodies questions like
that I don't usually the only time I ask
people their body count is when I say is
body count important and they say no and
then I say then what's your body count
but the point isn't to get their body
count the point is to show it's
important right because otherwise
everyone would just be like this you
know so um on this show as a joke I was
like what's he has his body count and I
said haha you don't have to say it's
okay like I was kidding she's all this
Pro sex girl so she's like oh I'll say
it to get rid of the stigma are you sure
she says yes okay go ahead go ahead this
girl threatens to sue me because she
said her body count on live that's
ridiculous why did you say
it's a litigious people oh my God